es gibt einfach die schnauze wie von dem
mann um gold ihr habt ja ja ja gedauert
ecke dornige dornige dauernd begriffen
die hand ich musste und ziehen und jetzt
hier t shirt nummer
ich weiß es ganz und herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen folge minecraft heute
spielen wir meine wahrscheinlich
lustigste und schwierigste challenge
aller zeiten ich stand hat eben auf dem
balkon und habe mir natürlich wieder
mama darf gedacht für euch eigentlich
spitzen challenge und die challenge
heute lautet für jeden fehler den ich
mache muss ich mir ein weiteres t shirt
anziehen ich fange an mit hellem t-shirt
mit dem was ich gerade an hab ich habe
heute nur eins an
normalerweise hat natürlich immer drei
an aber leute nicht doch love is here
den chats und guck mal unten und jetzt
für jeden den ich um lege werde ich mir
ein weiteres feature anziehen ich habe
keine ahnung wie das klappen soll vor
allem ohne waffe wird schwierig aber ich
sage wir finden jetzt eine und zwar
genau ihre tür zumachen weil man
reingeht muss gelernt werden
hallo ich habe gesagt ich finde eine
waffe ich kann doch nicht wahr sein es
kann nicht wahr sein als wäre ich einen
hügel ist wirklich keine waffe drin
ob fakten rüberspringen komm komm gib
mir eine waffe geht meine waffe gibt mir
eine waffe bitte bitte bitte bitte
donnerstag gesagt kann man kann man kann
kommen
ich hab mir das erste schon auf meinem
schoß bereit gelegt so dass ich direkt
wenn ich ein gegner treffen
loslegen kann und ich laufe einfach mal
hier los und suche mir an haye gegen
ergo bist du gegen r
gegen eher wie eine fluglinie die immer
in die falsche richtung fliegt sowie
gegenverkehr gegenverkehr europas oft
die boxen sich anschaulich ab wie sie
sie weiß dass man es erkennt dass man es
okay und wir ziehen unser erstes die
schon bitte bitte bitte jetzt mal die
kopfhörer ausziehen frischen luft ist
für alle da erkennen ein fettes schaut
euch mal das nächste titel bereit
eins ist sicher meine haare werden heute
auf jeden fall direkt so einfach nur
noch einen kopfhörer eine sport mehr
zeit
diese phase einfach wenn man sich das
t-shirt anzieht man denkt einfach dass
man die ganze zeit weg geklatscht wird
die ganze zeit man wird einfach die
ganze decke klatschen stück nur zwei
drei mal richtig schwierig wird auch vor
allem so eine runde zu gewinnen
mit meinem ersten abschnitts glück
gehabt vielleicht wenn so zwei gegner
direkt miteinander sind mache ich erst
die zwei kissen zidan dass die schon mal
schauen wo es potenzial überhaupt kein
fuß direkt oder indirekt manke und der
nächste gegner ist da drüben
er kommt er kommt er kommt er kommt wo
ich habe eine abwahl von der sand kommt
genau gehe da
zick zack zack und noch ein zweites
anziehen
okay noch mal eins hat der artikel
aufstieg ist auch gemacht nein nein jörg
butt bleibt weg lasse ich mein t shirt
anziehen
okay dass jemand mich anziehen nein ich
wurde oft ich hab mein schwert nicht
ausgewählt getan
ich hab keine kopfhörer der leute ist es
los er geht davon ja wohl okay jetzt
muss ich wieder zwei tests anziehen
jungs los vor den sommerspielen ok
zumindest mal richtung nächster gegner
schauen
fix ja nix fix ich mache fix maximal ich
fix als er hier so dass s t shirt ohne
branding das hier ist westliche arbeits
t shirt adam hornig präsent das kennt
weiß was abgeht und ich bisher 1
anziehen
hier ist einfach mein erwartet options
bisschen höher verkehrt es gab laute bei
der pop und hier ist nike er danke für
80 danke danke dann damit ich noch mehr
80 krieg in dem laden und man fühlt sich
etwas übertrieben aufgepumpt aber so als
hätte mal einfach nur brustmuskeln und 0
armmuskeln ok ich hab' kopfhörer dran
deathmatch starteten zehn sekunden
bitte nicht im deathmatch
gott wie viel gegner sind es könnte ein
recht kurzes video werden aber es wird
auf jeden fall ein knackiges ich hab
noch ein t shirt was sie parat liegt 1
was ich auch sehr gerne habe das sale of
t shirt aus dem mac im moment ist
michael moore kommen
okay der eine hat in einer der andere
hat den eingekehrt und so weiter da
einer den anderen
ich bin simon um gold ich bin um gold
lass mich an dich töten ich bin um gold
die ficc fixed a bug fix ich mache es
möglich für dich nämlich nein nein ich
auf mich nicht gewonnen
ich habe schon so viele t-shirts an
künftig gegen mich was ich wissen was
ich mache ich lege mir einfach mal ein
zweites tief schon bereit
just in case der stadt so kühl ist
krankhafter okay ich bin krank rafter es
gut zu wissen dass ich krank bin
nachdem ich wäre sein bruder roth r wie
die fluglinie die kleine grüner
transportiert und wachsen lässt ich
hab's schon hier unten auf dem schoß
legen ist das an spontan ein bete ich
bin ziemlich angreifen jetzt gibt es ein
auf die schnauze wie von dem mann um
gold ja ja ja ja ja gedauert
dauernd bitte kommentieren sie muss die
wir uns sehen darunter technik ich
glaube es nicht nein bitte bitte lass
mich anziehen
er greift nicht direkt an danke soweit
phoenix ich werde dich überleben weil du
bist und jetzt hier t shirt nummer ich
weiß es garantiert mitgezählt
t shirts
bright falls nicht könnte es kugeln als
würdet ihr es exakt in die suche
eingeben
ok ok go hat mich warten lassen alter so
geil litern schlapp ich fasse es nicht
ich fass es nicht
habe ich eine angel ja ich hab eine
angel wie sollte den fall ich geschossen
so schnell gewechselt
fahrzeugen um gold aber ich bin doch die
man um gold zuvor hatte ich warum
entstand ich nicht warum entscheide ich
nicht
ja ja ja ja ja der hat nicht mehr viel
der hat nicht mehr viel da hat nicht
mehr viel
für viele junge ich habe nur zwei herzen
der war auch richtig laut sage ich erst
mal steinschaden erst mal scheint
continental mit einem partner allerdings
jetzt hier ja kommt oft vor bald zwei
level
junge junge junge junge junge wie viel
hast du das gefühl dass er mich gut mit
pfeil trifft aber ich kann nichts machen
wenn ich jetzt rankommt baustand er mich
mit seinem power bogen fast noch weil in
deinen powerball oder gehe ich auf
einmal vielleicht angler meile
ich weiß es nicht
sollen wir drauf oder nicht wir haben
jetzt einen leichten damage vorteil im
nahkampf 025 schadens punkte er mit
sechs aber ich habe auch keine nerven es
heißt werde mich in brand setzen muss
ich mich schon eine üble combo geben
über den kongo vorteil haben eine chance
zu haben
es wird sehr schwierig die untere ohne
endet automatisch mit 90 sekunden leute
wünsche mir glück wünscht mir glück und
er weiß nicht dass ich einen schalter
das start-up nein gott nein macht nicht
dick
ja ja wir es geschafft wir haben es
geschafft leute wie fucking alter oder
auch es kann ja nicht krank crafter mein
lieber wenn euch das video gefallen hat
lassen like da alter geile fans sehr
schön wunderbar bis dann leute aus rein
haut rein unter bis zum 2